en el vídeo pasado estábamos hablando
acerca de los enlaces igme y déjame los
dibujos por aquí tenemos aquí dos
núcleos de dos átomos y vamos a dibujar
dos órbitas híbridas sp3 que tiene aquí
un pedazo pequeño y otro un poco más
grande
y esta es otra órbita híbrida del otro
átomo y estábamos diciendo en el vídeo
pasado que un enlace sigma es un enlace
en el que las órbitas que están
involucrados en el enlace o sea estas
dos órbitas se intersecta en este pedazo
en un punto que está en medio de los dos
núcleos ok si trazamos una recta que
pasa por los dos núcleos la intersección
de los dos órbitas está sobre la línea
aunque este es un enlace sigma
hace sigma y bueno también hay unos
enlaces que se llaman enlaces pi y estos
otros enlaces y suceden déjame los
dibujo por aquí dos núcleos que están un
poquito más pegados y el enlace ocurre
con orbitales de tipo p los orbitales de
tipo p tienen esta forma de mancuernas y
además estos orbitales de tipo p tienen
que estar paralelos y la intersección
aquí lo pueden ver sucede en dos partes
de estos orbitales de un lado y del otro
aunque estas dos intersecciones juntas
forman
en la cee
y en general utilizan esta letra griega
porque generalmente los enlaces ocurren
entre orbitales del tipo p y pues pi es
la letra griega equivalente a p pero
bueno estos enlaces sigma son muchísimo
más fuertes que estos enlaces pili y en
realidad éstos en la sesp y sólo los
vemos cuando ya tenemos un enlace sigma
y se construye un enlace doble o un
enlace triple ok y ahorita vamos a ver
el caso del etileno para que quede claro
cómo se combinan estos dos tipos de
enlaces entonces pues vamos a ver al
heleno que está construido de esta forma
tiene dos carbonos y estos carbonos
están unidos por un enlace doble
cada uno de estos carbonos tiene además
un enlace con dos hidrógenos que un
hidrógeno dos hidrógenos y otros dos
hidrógenos por acá pero bueno vamos a
hacer por aquí un dibujo de más o menos
cómo se ven los orbitales de todos estos
átomos pero para eso vamos a tener que
empezar a hablar acerca de orbitales
híbridos sp2 y antes de eso me gustaría
recordar un poco al metano y recordar lo
que vimos en el vídeo pasado a ver
tenemos por aquí el metano metano que
como vimos en el vídeo pasado es un
carbón que hizo cuatro enlaces con
cuatro hidrógenos hay un hidrógeno por
aquella que está como que saltando de la
pantalla hacia ti hay un hidrógeno que
se queda digamos que en la misma página
que la pantalla luego hay otro hidrógeno
que se está metiendo hacia el fondo de
la pantalla y un hidrógeno hacia arriba
también en el mismo plano de la pantalla
aunque hay como un triple y vimos en el
vídeo pasado
el carbono hacia estos enlaces con los
hidrógeno si quedan enlaces sigma y
también vimos que cuando el carbono
hacia un enlace con todos estos
hidrógenos sus orbitales cambiaban y se
transformaban en orbitales híbridos sp3
tenemos por aquí 11 s el orbital 1s y
tiene 2 electrones y si encontramos un
carbono solito sin que haya hecho ningún
enlace entonces tiene un orbital 2s y un
orbital 2 px y 12 20 y 12 pz
y tiene sus electrones acomodados por
aquí sin embargo vimos que cuando el
carbono hace enlaces con algunos otros
moléculas estos cuatro orbitales se
mezclan y por lo tanto los tenemos que
borrar y forman orbitales híbridos 2 s p
3 aunque forman cuatro de estos
orbitales 2 732 esp 3 y 2 s p 3
y además se coloca un electrón en cada
uno de estos orbitales haciendo un
enlace con las otras moléculas pero
además estos orbitales híbridos tienen
digamos que una naturaleza de 25% s y
75% p entonces así es como se formaban
los orbitales híbridos sp3 ahora
regresando con el eterno que bueno es el
etileno se le llama de las dos formas y
se le llama así es de dos y la
terminación en no o la terminación y le
no de que es un al que no y es al que no
porque tiene un doble enlace entre estos
dos carbonos pero bueno esta molécula de
etileno no va a tener orbitales como los
del metano sus orbitales ya no van a ser
híbridos sp3 pero ahorita va a saber a
qué me refiero con esto aunque entonces
vamos a ver la configuración electrónica
de este carbono que tiene pues tiene su
órbita el uno
con sus dos electrones y después pues
este carbono sigue teniendo sus cuatro
órbitas
además de la órbita 1s pero por el
momento no voy a ponerlas es decir los
peces y como podemos ver este carbono si
haciendo cuatro enlaces entonces sigue
teniendo sus cuatro electrones por él y
solitos cada uno en su órbita y lo que
va a pasar es que la órbita 2s se va a
mezclar con otras dos órbitas del tipo
psp2 psp 2 y sp 20 se va a quedar una
órbita del tipo p completamente solita
sin mezclarse con nada más gay y esto es
muy importante porque es esta órbita la
que va a provocar este doble enlace que
esta órbita del tipo p se va a juntar
con otra órbita del tipo p de este otro
carbono y van a formar este enlace pi
que le da una característica muy
importante a esta molécula porque
resulta que estos dobles enlaces como
uno de los dos enlaces es
y no permite que la molécula rompe pero
vamos a ver a qué nos referimos más
adelante entonces pues vamos a dibujar
las órbitas de esta molécula por aquí
tenemos por aquí este carbono y está el
núcleo de nuestro carbono y tiene su
orbital 1s alrededor del núcleo y además
tiene tres orbitales híbridos sp2 que no
es como los de cp3 que habíamos estado
dibujando pero se parece mucho una cosa
así con su cosita por acá y pues la
verdad me gustaría que pienses que esta
cosa está saliendo de la pantalla un
poco hacia ti luego por aquí tenemos
otro de esos orbitales híbridos sp2 que
se está metiendo hacia el fondo de la
pantalla y finalmente otro de estos
orbitales híbridos sp2 aunque ahí nos
falta dibujar este orbital de tipo p
pero eso lo vamos a dejar al último
antes vamos a dibujar este otro carbono
su núcleo está como por acá
también tiene su orbital de tipo 1s y
también tiene un orbital híbrido 2 sp2
como podemos ver aquí se están
interceptando estos dos orbitales y
además la intersección está entre los
dos núcleos entonces este es un enlace
sigma luego también este carbono tiene
otro orbital sp2 que sale de la pantalla
hacia nosotros pero nuestra dicción y
otro orbital que se mete a la pantalla
aunque ya antes de dibujar a los
orbitales de tipo p vamos a dibujar a
los hidrógenos entonces este hidrógeno
está por aquí y tiene únicamente un
orbital de tipo 1s con un solo electrón
girando por allí y también está este
hidrógeno por aquí con su orbital 1s y
este otro hidrógeno
y este otro hidrógeno
pero género ahora si te fijas aquí
tenemos muchas intersecciones de
orbitales y estas intersecciones de
orbitales pues si están entre los
núcleos de los átomos y por lo tanto
todos estos son enlaces sigma ok que son
en la sigma esto también se designa al
igual que éste
este bueno a ver este enlace de aquí
este en la suma de estos dos carbonos es
este enlace de aquí y estos enlaces de
aquí con los hidrógenos pues son estos
cuatro enlaces ok y ahora vamos a ver
qué onda con este enlace de por aquí y
este enlace pues resulta de la
intersección de las órbitas de estos dos
carbonos un crédito esta es una órbita
que no es híbrida es una órbita p y pues
la vamos a tener que dibujar muy grande
en generalmente no sería tan grande pero
pues necesitamos que se intersectan
entonces ni modo las tuvimos que hacer
muy grandes
obviamente estas órbitas son muchísimo
más simétricas pero pues no las podíamos
dibujar de una forma tan exacta aunque
podemos pensar que estas órbitas verdes
las órbitas híbridas sp2 están en un
plano y que estas órbitas amarillas que
son las órbitas p
ortogonal está ese plano o sea que
saltan hacia arriba del plano que
contienen las órbitas verdes pero bueno
si se fijan estás órbitas que se están
interceptando de una forma en la que se
intersecta un enlace pi en dos lugares
distintos y además esos lugares no están
en medio de los núcleos entonces estas
órbitas te están formando un enlace para
que éstas dos intersecciones son el
mismo enlace pi que bueno supongo que
debería de usar otro color que está en
la otra parte de este enlace y que en
realidad son el mismo enlace ti qué es
este enlace activo ahora este enlace
en sí pues es un enlace débil en
comparación con los enlaces sigma pero
pues estos dos átomos de carbono ya
están enlazados por este enlace sigma de
aquí que los mantiene unidos y pues este
nuevo enlace pi fortalece esa unión y
además proporciona una propiedad muy
interesante que es que ahora este átomo
de carbono no puede girar sin que este
otro átomo hill que sin nada más
estuviera este enlace sigma entonces
este átomo de carbono podría girar todo
lo que quisiera dejando a este otro
átomo de carbono sin moverse pero si
agregamos este otro enlace pi entonces
cada que este átomo gire por más poquito
que giren este otro átomo va a girar en
la misma dirección porque ahora están
más pegados con este la cepi y cada que
este átomo gire
este va a girar exactamente en la misma
dirección y con la misma magnitud esta
rigidez entre estos dos carbonos es lo
que está provocando el enlace pin
bueno y ahora podemos hablar un poco
acerca del equino al que también se le
conoce como acetileno que lo que son dos
carbonos pero ahora con un enlace triple
y bueno como aquí hay tres enlaces en
cada carbono no les queda nada más un
enlace para obtener un hidrógeno y aquí
lo que sucede es que estos tres enlaces
son enlaces de tipo sigma vamos a
escribirlo
son enlaces sigma y estos enlaces sigma
se formaron con órbitas híbridas s p esp
porque resulta ahora que estos carbonos
van a necesitar dos orbitales puros p
para poder hacer estos dos enlaces y
entonces ya sólo tiene un orbital p qué
puede mezclar con su orbital 2s así es
que los orbitales que forman estos
enlaces sigma son híbridos pero ahora
tienen una naturaleza 50% s del orbital
s del carbono y 50% p porque únicamente
estamos mezclando un orbital de tipo p y
pues estos otros dos enlaces son de tipo
p puro de hecho en este dibujo te lo
puedes imaginar aquí tenemos uno de esos
orbitales p de cada lado que forman este
enlace pi entonces mejor vamos a
dibujarlo de rojo y pues te puedes
imaginar otro enlace y así como quieres
al día
de la pantalla bueno dos orbitales uno
por cada carbono y estos dos orbitales
se intersectan en dos puntos uno
adelante de la pantalla y otro atrás de
la pantalla y forme un enlace pi bueno
espero que te haya quedado claro esto de
los enlaces signo y pin